[Музика]
привіт, привіт, мене звати Наталія, і настав
час для нашого уроку англійської мови, тому я сподіваюся,
що ви всі здорові та щасливі,
тому що ми знаємо, що нам потрібно для цього
виду спорту та хорошої їжі, давайте поговоримо про
спорт, перш ніж почати нашу  урок Я хотів
би, щоб ми побачили те, чого ми навчилися раніше,
чого ми навчилися зараз. Я впевнений, що ви
знаєте багато різних видів спорту, які ви знаєте,
як використовувати, грати і робити з усіма
видами спорту, про які ми говорили, найпопулярнішим
видом спорту  у світовому футболі, і тепер ви
можете вказати причину, чому ви любите той чи
інший вид спорту або ви його не любите, і ви
можете розповісти про свій спортивний досвід,
хороший чи поганий ми зробили невелику граматику з
модальними дієсловами can't mustn  ми не
дізналися про прислівники та як їх використовувати,
і ми дізналися, що тепер ми знаємо, що повільна
Рана
може виграти гонку, якщо цей бігун буде
працьовитим і продовжуватиме тренуватися та
вправлятися, а також ви виконували домашні
завдання, давайте перевіримо, що все гаразд, —
крикнув тренер  Голкіпер голосно номер
два ви вдарили тені  s м'яч дуже
потужний спосіб номер три
Соня красиво катається на ковзанах
номер чотири футболіст
впевнено штовхнув м'яч і забив гол
і останній я не почуваюся сьогодні я
залишаюся вдома відчуваю себе добре ми використовуємо тут прислівник
погано, тому що він описує слово
дієслово  відчувати це прислівник не об'єктивно добре,
зверніть увагу на це місце, а тепер як
щодо вашого власного спорту. У мене був варіант
шахового плавального м'яча, можливо, плавець
пливе в басейні з м'ячем,
і коли він досягає кінця
басейну, він робить  груди
рухайся та повертайся добре, дайте мені свої варіанти
, а тепер я хочу, щоб ви
склали кросворд про спорт
Я прочитав пояснення, і ви дасте
мені назву виду спорту давайте почнемо
номер один звідси зимовий вид спорту вам
потрібні ковзанки і ковзани  музика
що це
так, ви маєте рацію, це катання на ковзанах номер
два, тут ви можете робити трюки на
рахунок скейтборд у цьому виді спорту
що це так, це скейтбординг, хороша
робота
номер три  e це індуїстська
гра, ви кидаєте м'яч у кошик,
це
як баскетбол номер чотири, тут
спорт на свіжому повітрі, вам потрібен корт, ракетка
, сітка і м'яч, що це так,
теніс, добре попрацював і останні шість
водних видів спорту, вам потрібен вітер  і серфінг для
нього це легко віндсерфінг добре відмінно,
а тепер давайте трохи
посуємося, це невелика вправа, але з завданням з грама, якщо я
скажу цей порт, який ми використовуємо під час гри, ви
плескаєте в долоні, якщо я назву вид спорту,
який ми використовуємо  збираюся, якщо я
назву слово, яке вживається з ти просто
зігнутий вліво зігнутий вправо добре ще раз
спробуємо футбол плавання гарна йога
давайте зробимо це ще раз
плавання біг нормально баскетбол
характер біг підтюпцем катання на ковзанах шахи
аеробіка добре ми зробили невеликі
рухи і що далі  добре, у
спорті ми завжди змагаємося і порівнюємо, і
ми хотіли б бути вище стрибати довше
бігати швидше і citius Altius Fortius
це насправді слоган Олімпійських
ігор, ми дізнаємося їх пізніше, а
слоган означає швидко  ер сильніше вище і
це тема нашого уроку нашої
граматичної частини сьогодні наша граматика сьогодні
порівняння ступенів прикметників звучить
дуже страшно, але це не означає, що ми
порівнюємо щось порівняти pareve мінімальний
порівняти це порівняльний ступінь у нас є
два ступені порівняння  і
чудовий ступінь порівняльний ступінь - це
коли ми порівнюємо дві речі, наприклад,
я сильний, але ти сильніший, сильніший
у кращому ступені ми не порівнюємо
дві речі, у нас є одна серед інших
найкраща найсильніша є деякі
правила, як ми робимо ці ступені  щоб зробити
порівняльний ступінь we just + e are
ending to make superlative degree we +
est ending and there, але є деякі
моменти, які ви повинні пам'ятати,
наприклад, у нас є прикметники короткі
голосні прикметники, остання буква буде
подвоєна велика більша, сказано більш сумний і
найбільший найсумніший двійник, коли у нас є
виписки, що закінчуються на y,
їх багато, ми змінюємо його на закінчення I + +
ER  g у порівняльному ступені та
змініть Y на I + + est у кращому
ступені BZ
birria zip найлегше, а останнє правило,
коли ми мали ціль, яка має
більше одного складу, довгі прикметники, як-от
popular, ми ставимо більш-менш перед
ним у порівнянні  ступінь і найбільше
всі випущені в чудовій мірі ми
також маємо рівний ступінь Мені подобається це так само зайнято
, як великий, такий самий, такий же, як
мудрий, настільки ж сильний, як і у нас також є
деякі нерегулярні ступені, які ми повинні
запам'ятати і вивчити це напам'ять добре
краще найкраще погано гірше найгірше і
далеко
Телеко батько невпевнений і найдальша
ніч і вона добре, тепер давайте тренуємо нашу
англійську давайте вправляти нашу англійську добре
я читаю речення і ми відчиняємо
гальма всі знають, що Кевін -
це Еллен ми порівнюємо дві речі  тому ми
використовуємо тут сильніше, так, сильніше, ніж
Еллен, номер два впевнені, що це Z mm
баскетбол може відповідати я коли-небудь бачив, ми
не порівнюємо, ми просто говоримо про одну
найкращу річ, і у нас є тут
найцікавіше  баскетбольний матч так, ти маєш
рацію,
номер три, щоб бути ммм, ми повинні
займатися спортом, щоб бути тут, ми можемо бути
здоровішими або здоровими, я б вважав за краще
здоровий, тільки позитивний ступінь, щоб бути
здоровим, ми повинні звернутися за інформацією,
наступна вона, як вона  мати така ж розумна,
як і мати, однаковий рівень,
а останній Усейн Болт
найшвидший чоловік у світі,
але гепард гепард
швидший за нього, і це правда добре,
тепер подивіться на цю таблицю, давайте порівняємо
деякі види спорту, які ми маємо тут
теніс футбол катання на лижах теніс і
ролики, і у нас є ціни на
спорядження для кожного виду спорту та
рейтинг безпеки, п'ять зірок у
найбезпечнішому виді спорту, а дві зірки –
найнебезпечніший вид спорту, тож ви можете вибрати вид
спорту та порівняти їх, як у
прикладі для  приклад теніс подивіться
на теніс теніс ми тут
теніс дорожчий дорожчий,
ніж футбол так спорядження
дорожче, ніж футбол, але менше небезпек,
що футбол так менш небезпечний, тому що  використовуй
тут, у нас є п'ять зірок за безпеку. Я можу
дати твоїм батькам добре попрацювати, йти
далі,
зараз ми можемо сказати, що нам подобається,
а що ні, і тому, що у нас є
причина для цього, причина полягає в тому, що
один вид спорту кращий або більш захоплюючий  або
цікавіше за інший ми можемо
порівняти і вибрати один із видів спорту,
наприклад, я люблю футбол я люблю футбол,
тому що це цікавіше, ніж теніс,
але я не люблю шахи, тому що це
найнудніший вид спорту в світі, тому
подумайте про свій варіант  ваша
підготовка, що вам подобається, що вам
не подобається, і чому
добре, відмінно, продовжуйте, і тепер ми бачимо
, що це найшвидший
чоловік у світі,
так, він Рана, я прочитаю невелику
статтю про нього, і ми
попрацюємо  Гаразд
Арана, він народився на
Ямайці 21 серпня 1986 року, коли
був дитиною
Хусейн грав у крикет і футбол
на вулиці зі своїми братом і сестрою,
він дуже добре грав у крикет, коли Син
ходив до школи, він почав бігати  g він був
одним із найкращих бігунів у школі, він
все ще грав у крикет, але навіть його тренер
хотів, щоб він став спортсменом, тому Хоссейн
почав бігати на змаганнях, він виграв
багато перегонів, коли йому було п’ятнадцять років, у 2004 році
Хуссейн біг на Олімпійських іграх в Афінах,
але  він не виграв медаль, тому що
мав травму ноги, але чотири роки потому,
брав участь у Олімпійських іграх у Пекіні і
виграв три золоті медалі, він також побив
рекорд у кожній гонці, о, сказавши, що обоє любить
танцювати та дивитися футбол, що його
улюблена команда  Англійський «Манчестер
Юнайтед» називає його блискавичним м’ячем,
добре, це історія про втрату
обох найшвидших людей у світі, а тепер ск
жіть мені, що правда і що падає, ко
и вивіска була в дитинстві, він до
ре грав у крикет чи правда та
, це правда  його тренер хотів, щоб він
став гравцем у крикет-критик, це правда, ні,
це неправда,
він хоче золоту медаль на Олімпіаді по суті
ні, він не зробив, у нього була травма ноги, але
він виграв три медалі на Олімпіаді в
Пекіні, це правда так, я  це правда, що
зітхання обоє любить співати ні він не
любить танцювати, його улюблена футбольна
команда - англійський Манчестер Юнайтед,
це правда, так, це правда, і люди називають
його супербігун ні не супер нейрон, а
блискавка, добре, подивіться на
ці слова  слова, які починаються з
великої літери Y Усейн Болт
Олімпійські ігри Ямайки всі ці слова є власні
іменники власні іменники ім'я конкретної особи
місце або річ
О знак м'яч це ім'я Ямайка
це місце серпень це
місяці унікальна подія Олімпійські ігри
суть назва міста  переїдання також
Англія Манчестер Юнайтед і
блискавка всі ці слова є іменниками власними
пам'ятайте, ми починаємо їх з великої
літери далі добре
книга рекордів Гіннеса що це хто
знає так це книга, яка публікується
щороку і є список
світових рекордів за  людиною чи природою, тож
якщо ти хочеш бути кращим чи дістатися до
цієї книги, тобі слід наполегливо попрацювати,
є кілька кумедних та цікавих
прикладів  з цієї книги для прикладів 7
почекайте, студент із Флориди пройшов
1080 разів за одну хвилину, це
рекорд світу, найшвидший час, щоб
розгадати три кубика Рубіка під час
жонглювання належить хлопчику з Китаю, його
рекорд 5 хвилин
дві точки сорок три секунди він був
фантастичне жонглювання та розгадування лобка,
а останнє найдовша відстань, щоб
розтягнути домашній слиз за 30 секунд,
зроблений дівчиною з Нью-Йорка сім футів
чотири дюйми більше ніж два метри
за 30 секунд
дуже цікаво добре, і останнє завдання
для цього уроку полягає в тому, як  щоб висловити свою
думку електронною поштою на попередньому уроці,
ми дізналися, як висловити свою думку,
прочитавши якусь байку, якийсь текст, але
тепер у нас є лист від одного друга
до іншого та від Девіда до мережі, і
Девід попросив свого друга висловити свою думку,
який вид спорту він  варто вибрати
скейтборд або баскетбол, давайте прочитаємо
це.
Привіт, ви запитали мене про мою думку,
який вид спорту вам слід вибрати:
скейтборд або баскетбол,
скейтбординг  чудовий спосіб насолоджуватися
на природі, але це дорого,
є багато спорядження, яке можна придбати, наприклад
шолом для скейтборду та спеціальний одяг,
і це дійсно небезпечно
баскетбол дуже захоплюючий і не
так дорого грати, він навчає вас командним
навичкам, але це також може бути небезпечно  ви
можете легко постраждати від мене обидва порти
чудові, оберіть той, який вам найбільше подобається,
дайте мені знати, як все йде, чи все добре
в такому електронному листі, який ви повинні були запланувати,
перш ніж почати, написати це
добре на початку ми маємо
вітання привіт  о, привіт, тоді наступне у
нас вступне слово вступне слово
вступне слово це означає, що ви
вказуєте причину, що ви маєте рацію щодо причини
або вказуєте тему, яку ви можете використовувати, ви сказали
, що думаєте про Т, тому що я повинен зробити свої
професійні шоу, які ви просили  що стосується моєї думки
щодо UTP - Mahir, ви зробите мене за, ви
запитали мене, що я думаю про
Tippett - багато хто показує, що ви робите Mui pro,
це вступне зауваження, тоді є
основна частина тексту цього електронного листа
про хорошу думку або ба  d вказує на
причини, чому при наступному використанні ви висловлюєте свою
думку, що ви думаєте, я думаю, або, на
мою думку, це фрази, які ви можете використовувати
тут, і заключні зауваження, удачі,
до побачення, дайте мені знати, як це відбувається
da naboo Sherman, але ми знаємо, що це
розділяє  закон або дайте мені знати, як ви
впораєтеся і тримайте мене в повідомленні ваше ім'я,
давайте перевіримо, чи є всі ці частини
в нашому листі в цьому листі добре, ми
маємо високу ціну так це вітання
зараз вступне слово так ви запитали мене
про мою думку  бла-бла-бла-бла,
це вступне зауваження, наступні хороші
моменти та погані моменти та причини,
тут
скейтбординг - це чудовий спосіб
насолоджуватися прогулянками на свіжому повітрі. Баскетбол дуже захоплюючий
і не дорогий, це головна
частина, тоді ваша думка для мене обидва види
спорту чудові  це моя думка, але ви
повинні вибрати те, що вам найбільше подобається,
а заключні слова дайте мені знати, як це
відбувається, і назвіть Давида,
щоб у нас був план і лист, і
в кінці нашого уроку я хотів би
, щоб ви зробили  невелика коротка вікторина виберіть
деякий час правильний опис варіанту, а
три варіанти виберіть один гравець, чия
робота полягає в тому, щоб зупинити м'яч, щоб він не пішов у хід,
це іти ловець воротар чи робити воротар
ваш варіант так воротар номер
два місце, де така гра, як  теніс
грають на трасі або на корті. Ваш
варіант корт добре попрацював і
останній шматок дерева, який використовується для удару по
м'ячу в бейсбольній чи крикетній битій, колода та
ракетка, ваш варіант, ставка гарна, так що і наш
наступний дивний вид спорту в нашому звичайному виді
спорту ви коли-небудь  чув про ви коли-небудь
чули про всі вуличні перегони всі вуличні
перегони так
, до речі, є такий вид спорту бідні тварини добре ваше домашнє
завдання, будь ласка, напишіть своєму
англомовному другові електронного листа про свою
думку, який вид спорту йому вибрати
віндсерфінг чи біг  на YouTube із
цим відео ви можете знайти наш приклад, ок,
інше домашнє завдання — це діапазон цих портів
від найнебезпечніших до найбезпечніших,
найнебезпечніших, найбезпечніших, які ви можете використовувати за допомогою цього
sp  або, о, ви можете додати свій власний вид спорту,
який ви обираєте, і створіть свій
вид спорту, сноуборд
, каное, сноуборд і каное,
що це може бути,
використовуйте свою уяву Медіні, і давайте
подивимося, що ми сьогодні дізналися,
порівнявши сьогодні зі видами спорту, про які ми написали електронний лист
висловлюючи свою думку, який вид спорту
вибрати і чому ми читали
статтю про найшвидшого людини в
світі і навіть дізналися, хто продавав
кубики Рубіка, жонглюючи найшвидшим
ладно ось кінець нашого уроку будьте
здорові і щасливі і до побачення
[Музика]
ти